YEAH,I NERALLY NOHI T
DO.
LAN COLLINS, THANKS  M
W WEEKS, BUTE OW
PRS  WAS
N'S ISSUES MSE CLASSIFIED DOME
DOCUNTIL SERVED INED CBOCTSIED
INFORMATION.
TED OVER AND OVER NO  T LAWN DMS
EN R ENFOR ALL LAWS ROTECTION O
NDF AS
THFORMATION. NEED THBE FOERHAPSN
INE FACES 37 N
ARD TOD
DOCUS RE HE WOULD
E,AR
CAHE THIS
IN PARLATORE IS
THAT THERE ARE 3
DOCUMENTS OF AND PARLORE WA
ARE THE ONLY OSE
SERIOU YOU SAY ACCOR
TO EXPERTS THAT'NOT THE
R
CO THISFORE I SPOKE TORICE DEPO
INDICTMENT COMES OUT WHEN YOU
ARE DEALING WITH HIGITATERIAL,
TO THE CIADOD,F E,WHAT CAN WE H
SO IT IS LIKEL T
UMENTSD THIST ERME
EENTKAN
LIVE WITH THESE
NDTH
DOARHOWN TJURY, RIT?RE NOT READ
OMLL Y SENSITIVE?
ACTUALLY TAKPLE FOR EACH OF AT'N
>> REDACTED OR
>> SO THEYIL
AS
PROTECTION ACT OO COME
UP WITH A SERIF REDACTIONS SITE
E END TO THE JUR
NOW, IT'S IMPORTAN KNOW ATPIECE
GEINE INTELLIGENCE
MMUNITY TO AGREE TO F
DOCUMENTS IN THE COURSE OF
GATION
MANY ENA CASES NEVER O COURE
GET THATEE WILLING TLLICE THE S
REASON THAES
CIISY T
COULD HAVE BEEA WORSE, IT
DOCUMENTS IN THE THAT  T PROBABA
THEY COLLECTED FROHOWEVER MANY
NARA, THERE ARE PROBABLY
AT COULDN'T BE AGREED TO BE
EXPOSED IN LITIGATE
UTCESS. HAT WERE SO SENSITIVE OH
>> LIKE WHAT
OBVIOUSLE US
THE DETAIL BUT OBVIOUS WHA
VLIKE WHERETHINK IRAN HAS ITSU?
>> A LOT OF
AN OES  OLDER NOW
SOURCE OR HO THE LOCATIO MAYBE T
CONTENT OF SOME OF THESE
CU PUBLICLY SO THEY ARE N
AS S
CLASSIFIED AND YOUKNOW, PEITIVE
STUFF.
SO THERE ARERE WUARE THAT .
AGREEMENRO INTELY,OCUMENTS, E 3
THROUGH HE1 NOT NECEIL31 WORST.
JUST THE 3IGENCEMU
SIGN OFF ON AND AL COURT?
>> ON THE R HAND THE
PROSECUTORS NTE TO USE.
>> RIGHT.
>> IT'S GOING TO PKE
PROTECTIVE AND EMOACTION FROM JT
I'M CONFIDENT THAT EACONE HAS BN
CONCERN THAT THE CST
INFORMATION.NECESSE
793 GEHIE CH
3COUNTS. >> LAST QUESTIONN TH
DOES THIS NOJURY
HEY AT RISK --  A GRAND JURY --D
THE GRAND JURY SDOCUS, NO? GRAN
THIS NOT SUBJECT
HT WAN KNOW Y AND THE JURYGHT,
WHAT THEY KNOWAT
LEARNED,VEA
SATIZED VERSION?
>> THE JURORE CES.
IGT THEY'RE GOING TO
THESE DOCUMENTS.  THEY WILL RE
OF THE DOCUMENTSMA
SUMMARY, MAYBE IT'S A REED
TOIMIT THE W MENT TO T
DAMAGE TCOU
FROM HAVI FOLKS WITHOUEAG
VE ON A JURYNATIONECGE
REON IT'S
SOMETHING THATS TAKEAND IT DOESA
POSITION. >> REMEMBER, A
TRIAL JURY THAT YIDABLE C
TOOIR DIRE YOUR RY
DRAW, WHOEVER IS
AND JURY ESA OFG THAT
SOMEHOW AS TAYLORMAD
BE FATALLY UNDERNE
E .
OUTLINED CLION THE ATEMENT YOU
EDO .
FINAEN YOU THINK ABOUT ALL
OF FOCUS ON THE LEGA
E DEFENS
T SAIDTHIS WAS
AN A DUMR 20OC O31
THEY HAVUBWN TO
SUGGT ATTHEY'VE RGUMENT RT
FILING, IN HE WAED TO RETAIN TH
W THE ANSWERO QUESS.
Y  DODID YONT THESE
DOCUMENTS?
AND WHY HAVE Y TO  RETEN
RECLAMATION OF DONS TH
WILLIN
OUT THERE AND HAVE YET TO BE
ANSWERED.
PAC, IT SEEMS ESPECIALLY IN THE
AUAPANCE, HEAS
O USE ST -AMPLE. TO USE CD AINS
WEAPONIZING IT A LITTLE BIT OF .
OFHY H
IT'SOT
THOUW
TRUMP FOR HIM TOTOD  T
I KND